après le film
le spectacle avatar le plus grand succès
cinéma box office en forme de plus de 2
milliards de dollars de recettes
jusqu'ici eh bien ça prendra vie tout ça
dans un spectacle créé à montréal par le
cirque par le cirque du soleil pardon
avant d'être présentés partout dans le
monde fin 2015
tanya lapointe famous movie à votre or
c'est un bon coup et un défi de taille
le ciel du soleil adaptera pour un
spectacle en aréna le plus lucratif des
films de l'histoire du cinéma
avatar a connu un succès retentissant à
sa sortie en salle en 2009 un film en 3d
tirées de l'imaginaire de james cameron
le réalisateur canadien mise sur
l'expertisé de la compagnie de guy
laliberté pour produire une expérience
immersive à la hauteur des attentes des
fans de la première heure cette
production dépassera les 25 à 30
millions de dollars
normalement versées par le cirque pour
ses spectacles sous chapiteau
ce qui est important pour nous surtout
c'est qu'on veut pas faire de compromis
au niveau de la qualité du spectacle on
veut le faire dans des paramètres
financiers qui soient correctes aussi
pour que l' aventure soit profitable
pour nous et pour nos partenaires ayant
déjà film est un documentaire sur le
cirque du soleil
james cameron connaît bien le potentiel
et les limites de ces artisans which is
god
le spectacle sera conçu à montréal avec
la contribution entre autres des
metteurs en scène victor pilon et michel
lemieux ces dons extraordinaires
d'amener quelque chose comme avatar et
de donner ça à des créateurs d'ici
ça c'est ma plus grande fierté la
création de ce spectacle s'était fait
jusqu'à présent dans le plus grand
secret james cameron découvrira
d'ailleurs vendredi les premiers
extraits de cette mégaproduction qui
sera présenté en première mondiale à la
fin 2015
ici tanya lapointe radio canada montréal